if you know a lot about football you'd
say he's a really good football player
if you don't know much about it and say
who's 21. you know he's got straw if you
will that stirs our drink the more
weapons you have the better everybody is
come on z that was ezekiel elliott at
his athletic fest come outside right can
he out he ran over a guy
defeat him feed him free to beat him
stop him
they can't hand off elliott big hole up
the middle
touchdown elliot there's your ball game
you don't have to have a russian
champion to win a super bowl we miss the
player that he has been he's a good
friend obviously you want him out here
but that's business
[Applause]
ezekiel trying to get a lot more than
those few dollars he put to the
salvation army kettle last year that's
for damn sure and you know what we
haven't heard
anything from zeke since he began his
hold out now he did an interview with
maxim.com
last month whatever that means because
his holdout began july 26th i would
guess this was before july 26th and
they're taking liberties with last month
to create the impression that maybe it
was a post holdout interview
he said that he said a lot of
interesting things he said for example
he wants to be a cowboy for the rest of
his life hopefully that's a possibility
even emmitt smith the greatest running
back ever ended up going to play a
couple of years for another organization
so it's just the nature of the game but
i want to be a dallas cowboy for as long
as i can that's fine yes but you know
the cowboys
don't want to overpay for the running
back position and if they think they are
then they start looking in another
direction and that was the other point
that zeke made pointing out the recent
deal that todd gurley did with the rams
he said i think there was an undervalue
of the running back but with guys like
gurley getting drafted so high then me
and now guys like saquon barkley getting
drafted in the first round i think we've
done a great job of bringing back the
value of the position showing the
importance of
the running back and i think that
the more accurate point is
they're showing the importance of the
elite workhorse that's what it is it's
exactly right the running back itself
right time it doesn't yeah respect to
all running backs out there but every
major college program produces a running
back every year that has a chance to
compete in the nfl level there are too
many of them pretty much great running
backs there aren't enough of them those
are the guys who have value yeah you're
exactly right and i think you put it
exactly right yes there's a lot of good
running backs in the nfl a lot of good
ones and if you have a good offensive
line and a good offensive system you can
make do but there's only a few elite
ones where they're true game changers
and if you're watching on tv you saw a
graphic there but i mean the ones that
jump out to me right now are ezekiel
elliott todd gurley when he's healthy
certainly i think david johnson is in
that category okay i'm gonna throw him
in there when healthy when healthy again
right you're christian mccaffrey i think
you make a great point he's probably in
that category right now um i'm missing
something joe nixon could be on the
verge could be exactly right alvin
kamara's probably in that list as well
they don't use them enough maybe not and
maybe they will this year now that mark
ingram's out of there so i look at those
guys as kind of being in a class of
their own right and melvin gordon's
right on the edge of that as well but i
don't think he's quite in their class
and he he's true to that now the the big
thing with ezekiel elliott of course he
wants to be a cowboy for life who
wouldn't want to be i mean it's a dallas
freaking cowboys you know you're treated
like a king i was i played you know
football in the university of texas and
i certainly wasn't ezekiel and they
treated me like a king down there they
love football and to be associated with
that brand and be in that city
it is something that will stay with him
for the rest of his life so i understand
him wanting to be a cowboy for the rest
of his life um but i just hope the jones
family ponies up the money le'veon bell
too we forgot to put his yeah le'veon
belt and he's a guy who can get back
right into that category for now
the jury's out but i'll tell you what
based on some of the stuff that he's
done and we practice yeah
yeah he's he's back yeah he'll be back
it looks good but uh
look it's just the nature of the
position there are and hey i said this
last hour on the radio side
and it dawned on me about 15 years ago
when we go to the west virginia
university football games every week
every year there was a guy who came out
of that program who could get it done at
the next level right every program has
that guy they don't have quarterbacks
right you you don't you don't look at
every major college program and say
there's a guy that can play quarterback
in the nfl there's a guy that played
quarterback in the nfl right i mean
you'll hear that when you're watching
games because the announcers are kinda
yeah they don't know what they're
talking about yeah yeah that guy's gonna
be playing on sundays right no he's not
not unless it's at the park by his house
right but but uh for running backs it's
real they have a chance to do it for
quarterbacks and it's supply demand it's
that simple yes it's a more valuable
position because there aren't enough
guys who can do it well and what a
quarterback does is so much more
important to the overall team running
backs there's just too many of them but
there aren't enough great ones and the
way that the rookie compensation system
is set up you need to draw a line in the
sand after your third year you can't get
a new contract until after your third
year right if you're ezekiel elliott
three years in hold out right next year
christian mccaffrey hold out sorry
panthers fans the year after that saquon
barkley hold out yeah that's the only
way you get maximum value at a time when
you are giving maximum production agreed
and the good thing is with these elite
running backs they were drafted in elite
positions in the draft for the most part
because the team values truly running
the ball and they want to have that
mantra and attitude to where they're key
parts of the football team i mean like
we're seeing with ezekiel elliott no one
really believes in dallas unless he's
there i got to see everything else to
believe it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports